- [Man] Question I have for you.
- Yep.
- [Man] What does your
day actually look like?
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Ethic" by Justin Stone)
The other route we can go,
the other route we
can go is level this up,
make it more
valuable to the people
and subsidize it.
Yo.
- [Man 2] Yo.
- So I called this meeting
because I have this ambition
that I've not been able to
accomplish yet which is do a
quarterly or two times a year
all hands on town hall where all
it really is one
massive Q&amp;A session with me.
- You're trying to make the
things that are gonna benefit
you--
- Yes, yes.
- and you do that
by being selfless.
- Correct.
- As well.
- It's why I win.
- That's a dichotomy
that's hard to grasp for me.
- It's why I'm gonna
be all-time great.
- Right. And so I think
the same with like--
- It's true.
- when it comes to
someone talking to you, right?
It's like cool, I want to be
about this company 'cause this
company is about this company,
it's about being Honey Empire
and so I need to be selfless.
- But I want
people to be selfish.
- Exactly.
- I'm comfortable with that.
- Right.
- I don't expect,--
- listen, if you got the
distributions of the profit of
VaynerMedia directly
to your bank account
then you could be selfless.
- [Man 3] Right.
- Do you know how much I make
fun of my friends when they tell
me things like, "How do you get
your employees to work
"as hard as you?"
I'm like, "You don't.
"What the fuck
are you talking about?
"You work for them." Right?
I get that.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- Yeah, man, look we're
gonna win because we're
having these
conversations, right?
One person in here moved 30% in
their score of this place 'cause
of this conversation
and then you build on it.
Right?
- [Man 3] Right.
- And then that leads to
six months from now something
happening and you come and talk
to me and then the way I react
to it changes
everything for you.
That's where we most win.
The reason I want the one-on-one
is 'cause what happens out of
the one-on-one.
That's where
we're building trust.
It's all actions.
That's where we're winning.
I love people who just want to
stay in their lane maybe get
one more, two more promotions,
have insane work-life balance.
Work 9 to 5 check out
of here every day at 5,
do their work that's valuable.
There's always an exchange.
I'm not gonna tell
you how to live your life.
I just want to provide a good
trade for you for that life.
Place you want
to work, good place,
the right like
you know what I mean?
And by the way, things change.
You're 24 and you want to
be the CEO of VaynerMedia.
You're 31 and in love, one kid
and you love like taking her to
soccer practice and you're just
not willing work 18 hours a day
to be the CEO of VaynerMedia.
It's all good for me.
We need them all.
I don't want to be in
charge of your ambition.
I just want to give you more
than you give me so that you
stay here forever.
You know?
It's important.
That's real life.
That lacks ideological POVs
and that is just practical.
Thanks for hanging.
Hit me up if you need me.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- Awesome.
- [Woman 2] Hi, I'm
here with Gary Vaynerchuk,
CEO of VaynerMedia, investor,
jack of many, many trades.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And host of the wildly
popular #AskGaryVee Show.
Thanks for being here today.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Woman 2] For Thrive Global.
- Thank you.
- [Woman 2] So you're
entrepreneurship goes way back.
Lemonade stands, baseball cards
and it turns out that
you're gonna be in 2047
the owner of the New York Jets.
- [Gary] That's the plan.
- [Woman 2] Is that right?
- That's right.
- [Woman 2] 30 years?
So you say that it's
gonna be 30 years
due to your behavior.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Woman 2] I once heard
Tim Ferriss say that someone had
told him what if you were to
condense that business plan that
lifetime business
plan into a year.
- Yep.
- [Woman 2] What would
that look like for you?
- It wouldn't
look like anything.
You know, it's so funny.
I answer every question always.
I'm sure they're
already laughing.
I couldn't even comprehend that.
It's just not my wiring.
That's like asking me hey
Gary, how do you start flying?
It's impossible.
I'd have to become a gambler.
Right, like, I'd have
to take all my assets and
do something crazy.
So, I'm a marathon runner.
Marathon runners
don't win sprints.
You know?
They just don't.
They don't have
the body shape for it.
They don't have the mentality.
They don't train like that.
It doesn't even feel
good when you ask me that.
- [Woman 2] Hmmm.
- And I genuinely
believe that's the
reverse of most entrepreneurs.
I think a lot of fake
entrepreneurs want to do this
for the watches and the private
jets and the champagne bottles
and the boats.
- [Woman 2] Certain aspects.
- Mhmmm.
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm.
- I just don't have it in me.
- [Woman 3] Hey Gary.
- Hi. How are you?
- Guys, it's been unbelievable
to watch entrepreneurship like
impact the whole world
but especially athletes and
really artists I think.
Just really thinking so much
smarter and it's amazing to
think like 15 years ago you guys
being interested in this stuff
was far less than it is today
and people are really thinkin'
about off the field and like
somewhere around fourth grade
I realized I was more likely to
buy the Jets than play for them.
Talk about
everything that you are.
So like what other
interests do you have?
And you may not have
any others, I don't give.
It doesn't really matter
as long as it's your truth.
It has to be your truth.
(Gary laughs)
Did dude get back to us?
- And everyone's loving it.
They're all supporting
'cause you know.
- [Gary] And what about a career
from social from the standpoint
of what happened on YouTube,
what happened on Instagram,
what happened on
Twitter, how did it,
give me the narrative.
(Taylor singing)
- [FatManScoop] This is
what we're doing?
This is what we're doing.
Vayner Water, hopefully
this is gonna make me
make good investments.
- Smarter. You get smarter.
Good to see you.
How you been, man?
- [FatManScoop] I'm good,
brother.
- It's good to see you again.
How was London?
- [FatManScoop] Good,
good, good.
Since the last time I saw you,
I've been to five countries.
- Tell me about,
help me understand where
your guys' world is at.
Tell me about
your career right now.
(group laughter)
- Now I'm like what do I do now?
So they were like come on
the GaryVee show 'cause Gary,
basically, this is
his life every single day.
This is episode what
episode 139?
- [Gary] 172?
- Nah, no 172.
- [Gary] 171. Right?
- [DRock] 173.
- So 173 is now my lucky number!
Okay, so 173 is my lucky number.
- [Gary] Oh, my man.
Pick 3, if you're in a state--
- [DRock] 174.
- [Gary] This is gonna be 174?
What just came out today?
- [DRock] 173.
- [Gary] Came out today?
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Gary] Alright, so
174 is your lucky number.
- So 174 is my lucky number.
- [Gary] Let me get, if
your state gets 174 in it's
Pick 3 today, send that in.
We got gifts for you.
So once I decided back in '09 it
was going to be a pillar of our
society, I started
really, really understanding
the business rationale.
The bottom line is,
and it's tried-and-true,
it happened long before hip hop.
When you are yourself
and you do not waver,
you will win if
you're good enough.
We'll be in touch.
- [Man 3] Okay.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Scoop, my man.
Much love.
Alright, let's do it.
- [Nicole] Of my kids
putting on Instagram,
it turned into
brands reaching out.
I went down this whole path
that I never even knew existed.
- [Gary] You're like, "Wait,
people will pay me to put this
"product in a
picture with my child?"
- [Nicole] Right, exactly.
Something that I love doing and
people started paying me for it.
I was alright, this is amazing.
- This I like, this I like.
- Yeah. This is really cool.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So I've been pursuing
that and worked with a
lot of good brands.
I've been reaching out to some
of my dream brands and I ended
up working with within a year
which I never
thought imaginable.
- [Gary] Just by DM'ing them?
- I put together
like a media kit.
Sent them an email.
- [Gary] Good.
- Showed them some of my sample
work and they gave me a shot a
couple times for
free and then eventually
I ended up getting paid.
- [Gary] Say that one more time.
- A couple times for free,
(laughs) and then I had to prove
myself and then--
- [Gary] One more time.
- (laughs) Yep, had to work
for free and prove yourself.
- This conversation
pisses me off.
The amount of people that
don't realize that free is
the gateway to paid.
- [Nicole] Mhmmm. Absolutely.
- [DRock] Yeah. It's my life.
- It's the three of ours lives.
(Nicole laughs) It's the
audacity to think that you're
not being compensated when
you're trying to get a shot in a
world where there's
a lot of photographers
taking pictures of their kids.
- [Nicole] Exactly.
- Supply and demand,
mother fuckers.
(crosstalk)
Let me get a copy.
Thanks, man.
How you been?
- Been really good.
Busy as hell just like you, man.
- On this episode,
the legend stops by.
Miguel, to answer your question,
I've now had a career for
20-plus years, I at every minute
was running one
of two companies.
Wine Library or VaynerMedia.
There was never a day in my life
where I didn't have something
that I call the
80% of what I do.
- That's right.
- That's exactly
what you were saying.
I call it the meat,
the main dish.
You can go and have
side dishes and if your meat,
if your steak is
perfect you'll always be able
to absorb the losses.
- That's right.
- Because they're
smaller losses.
And then when something
over here becomes bigger,
you can turn that into
the main part and that
can become the steak.
Too many people have all
side dishes and no steak.
("Relevant" by Blake)
It's fun to see Tony.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Big dude.
Just had a
monster meeting, monster.
Fucking fired up.
I've been quiet for the last
minute because I've been sending
emails about how
excited I am about it.
Nothing like a
good client meeting.
Real good.
I want to do it with you and so
I'm willing to do it for less.
Brand, brand.
I do things that are not
scalable that are about brand
and that's why
I think I'm winning.
First, I did a lot of
things before I took it over.
So I spent years chipping away
at him trusting me so he could
give me as much room as
possible to do my thing.
So sometimes kids go to
university and never work in the
business or do different things
and then they just show up as an
adult, and so you're starting,
so what's your situation?
You're in that situation.
- [Man] Yes.
- So, had you worked
in the business before?
- [Man] I've been
around but I haven't really--
- So that's the
part I don't know.
All you want is air cover to do
what you believe in and all the
parent wants is their own
balance of how much they believe
and don't believe in the kid,
how much they believe in and
don't believe in the
direction and how much
they still have in their tank.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] We finally figured
out how to bring value to small
businesses and
so that's the scoop.
Oh, by the way,
I've got another idea.
I'd love to get this thing.
Guys, you know Disney
and Zappos do this thing,
I've been thinking about doing a
12-hour digital media detox tour
at VaynerMedia for $10,000 a
head where you come in at 9 A.M.
breakfast,
there's a lunch keynote,
some days I'm here,
some days I'm not.
Basically, we'll go through all
our disciplines and we basically
do a one-day consulting sesh for
$10K where it's all based
around the Vayner world.
You tour here, different
days you meet executives.
I don't know if you guys know
this but we have old people too.
Like we have them.
(group laughter)
Really thinking about this
concept like Disney and Zappos
does where you spend 12 hours at
VaynerMedia for $10,000 a head.
I really think we can make it
valuable when I look at what
people are doing
for these $10,000 offer,
really trying to figure this out
so if you're interested in $10K,
I see a bunch of you
already answering that you are,
send me an email.
I promise you you'll be
the first people before
I announce it officially.
You'll be in the first beta run.
When you're tug-of-warring
why do you want to dig
into the family business?
- [Man] I think it's because
(inaudible) my parents for them.
- Yep.
- [Man] And the
upside potential of how big.
- You'll explode it, okay.
And what's pulling
you on the non-profit?
- [Man] Non-profit is
'cause there,
there are so many
needs in the world.
- Yes.
- You do to others
like you want unto you.
- [Gary] So I think
there's two debates.
Equal.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Legacy, huh? Love it.
Is it 50-50?
- [Man] Right now?
- Yeah.
Right this second.
- [Man] 60-40.
- Non-profit?
- [Man] Yeah.
- You should do
the the non-profit.
- [Man] Okay.
- You'll just
regret that you don't.
- [Man] I don't like regret.
- Me neither.
Meeting's over.
It's just obvious.
It seemed like
that's what it was for me.
Like, that's where I thought
you were gonna go and if you
answered 50-50 I was literally
going to tell you to flip a coin
and never look back.
But I love that you answered
60-40 'cause that's what
I felt was happening.
Just, that
would've been my guess.
I wish I wrote it down.
That would've been
cool for the camera.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- You should do it.
- [Man] Why the coin though?
- Well, if you're truly 50,
I hate people sitting on shit.
And I think there's
times when there's 50-50.
I have it.
I don't flip a coin,
I just literally say to myself
this is stupid,
this and I just go.
So there is times for 50-50.
The problem is 98% of the people
are sitting on 50-50 their whole
fucking life which
means they're 0-0.
So when you're 50-50, you get
one day and anything else is
you're just fucking sitting and
bullshitting so fucking flip a
coin, pick the one
and never look back.
But if you're truly 60-40,
don't spend any more time.
Don't underestimate
speed and action.
Moving is important.
'Cause you can
change the course.
You can stop doing, if you don't
give a fuck about what people
think you can do everything.
I know that's why I told you.
So good, go do the fucking NGO,
you'll never regret,
you'll never think back.
The lumber company's
gonna be there.
Dad's doing his thing and after
four months if you don't like
the way it tastes or you're
like fuck this or this and that,
you see what I mean?
- [Man] Yeah.
- But the quicker you
start the quicker you do.
- [Man] There's
something to that.
I've already started.
- Good. Do it.
Go all-in though.
- Yeah. Always.
- No more brain power to
should I do the lumber thing,
just go all-in and
then, do and watch.
Be in it and watch yourself
from above and just move,
constantly move.
Fucking change shit.
I got it go.
- Thank you.
- You got it.
- Can I say
something to the audience?
- [DRock] Yes.
- You guys watch a lot,
you guys watch his DailyVees,
he's great but at the end of the
day it comes down to execution
so get out there
and actually do shit.
That's it.
- [Tyler] Cool.
("Relevant" by Blake)